hélène buzzetti à la question gay
christian dufour bonsoir bons débuts de
ce soir va entend tout de suite la swing
et du québec compte deux clubs
enfin les gens qui suivent ceux de très
très très près la connaissais mais pour
le grand public
on lui a demandé de venir à l'aéroport
de prince élevé un message important
donné
madame le docteur aubrun ternie qu'on
écoute maintenant et on revient ensuite
les impacts sont énormes et se feront
sentir pendant encore plusieurs mois
voire des années en raison de retards
qui s'accumulent dans les listes
d'attentes
le choix des activités à délester qui
est prise en lien avec des groupes
d'experts étant de plus en plus
difficile à faire
alors avec quand c'est un rappel
aujourd'hui c'est ce que john tout début
d'émission de ce pourquoi on fait tout
chà les réseaux de la santé débordé et
des gens qui normalement devraient se
retrouver à l'hôpital pour des
opérations semi urgent mais ça peut être
très très sérieux qui n'y seront pas oui
c'est ce que le gouvernement a voulu
rappeler tout ce qu'on fait actuellement
le couvre-feu le prolongement du
confinement les services essentiels
commerce sont essentielles qui sont qui
sont fermées tout ça c'est pour diminuer
la pression sur le réseau hospitalier
pour qu'on ait la capacité de soigner
tout le monde si un accident de voiture
doit pas été obligé de choisir lorsque
la personne n'arrive à l'urgence qui on
doit sauver qu'on a le plus de chance de
sauver et madame au patronyme qui était
effectivement pour la première fois aux
côtés de françois legault aujourd'hui la
sous ministre adjointe qui grosso modo
est en charge la première ligne au
québec là un petit long comme le bras
mais si on résume sa est en charge la
première ligne au québec dictée on
n'avait même jamais imaginé qu'on serait
obligé de réviser le protocole qui dit à
qui on doit sauver la vie qui a le plus
de chances de survivre à dit mais là on
est obligé de former des gens en
accéléré nos travers la santé par
webinaire parce que dans quelques
semaines si la situation ne se calme pas
on pourrait obliger être obligé d'en
arriver là comme en italie comme à new
york s'est produit lors de la première
vague donc oui la situation elle est
très très tendue dans le réseau
hospitalier actuellement est là mais
c'est partout comme chara au oui
absolument et puis on entendu lequel
déjà des patients coded commence à être
transférés dans d'autres hôpitaux de
montréal vers d'autres régions etc
patrice je pense qu'on a on s'approche
du moment où l'ultime question tu avoues
se posera et c'est la question par
personne veut se poser mais en ce moment
où on assiste un peu à une forme de
racisme à l'expression de primes coved
c'est-à-dire que les personnes qui ont
cette maladie
elles sont toutes traitées mais la
question taboue reviendra un jour on
cela posera c'est à dire que est ce
qu'il ya des gens en ce moment contre
est alors qu'elles sont en fin de vie
ces personnes et qu'on versus des gens
qu'on délaisse parce qu'ils sont afin
que d'autres maladies et qui elle aurait
peut-être plus d'années d'espérance de
vie des rites devant elle c'est une
question extrêmement délicate personne
ne veut envisager cette d'avoir affronté
ça mais on approche de ce moment et il
faudra à un moment donné en parler parce
que le mot délestage est froid mais
c'est du tout séduit vraiment qu
attendent chez eux une intervention
chirurgicale rendez vous important une
greffe une chirurgie orthopédique qui
ont peine à marcher c'est du monde qui
attendent qu'ils ne peuvent pas avoir
accès qu'il signe du fort aux soins de
santé
oui on dit 140 chirurgie en attente
c'est beaucoup de monde donc croisons
les doigts des droits parce que c'est
toujours ce qu'on ne craint au fond
depuis le début de la pandémie la
situation italienne que le système de
santé en fait ça fait donc quoi dire
d'autre que c'est très très grave
ça peut aider les québécois à accepter
la dure réalité du couvre-feu
ce fait que qui est annoncé il ya cinq
jours
c'est clair que la situation sans arrêt
et dramatique et vocaux reçoit de bonnes
chances est aussi juge jouer les crétins
monsieur legault et je pensait jusqu'à
présent ces jeunes les discours
politiques ce sont des héros parce que
depuis mars qui sont soumis à une telle
pression
ils prennent d'édition tellement
difficile et leurs récompenses et
jusqu'à 5h certains points elle appuie
pratiquement totale de toute la
population
et moi je trouve que la période qui
s'annonce ça va peut-être être plusieurs
pour les décideurs politiques parce que
depuis la semaine passée depuis la
conférence de presse sur le couvre feu
il me semble qu'un débat politique qui
il râle réapparu depuis 500 jours et ça
va être difficile pour eux legault et
compagnie parce que la récompense
jusqu'à présent c'est que les gens
étaient unanimes
sauf que moi d'unanimité depuis le
couvre feu quand même bon parlons jean
duc ouvreur je vous fais entendre
monsieur legault qui a été premier
extrait de monsieur legault couvre feu
qui a été impressionnée dit il et même
toucher touché en école j'ai été
vraiment impressionné touchée de voir
comment les québécois ont suivi les
directives la première fois je pense au
québec qu'on un couvre-feu entre com -
ce que je me souvienne c'est une mesure
qui est grave parce qu'on a une
situation qui égale
bon alors qu'ici je redémarre avec vous
vous aviez des réserves
enfin beaucoup de gens avaient des
réserves le poids que vous mais sur le
couvre-feu faut dire que les ça c'est
plutôt passé quel mal il ya eu sept cent
soixante je crois 740 constats
d'infraction émis ce n'est pas rien mais
ça répète beaucoup plus associer très
très bien passé
les québécois ont été ce qu'ils sont un
peuple profondément pacifique et qui
respecte la loi mais je trouve que
mercredi passé il s'est passé quelque
chose quand même
lorsque le docteur à rudar est posée la
question de notre collègue sébastien
bovell est ce que le couvre-feu est liée
à une démonstration scientifique ou
sanitaires et monsieur abboud a avoué
que ce n'était pas le cas
donc ça veut dire que c'est une décision
qui était en bonne partie politique donc
on est dans le politique est dans une
démocratie libérale
quand on est dans le politique c'est
normal qu'ils aient des débats qui est
des questions et depuis cinq jours moi
ça me frappé de voir à quel point dans
les journaux un peu partout il ya des
gens qui sont mis à reposer des
questions
quelque chose dont on a beaucoup parlé
moi c'est le panel de céline galipeau
jeudi soir au téléjournal auquel
participait une buse et ti paul wells
puis sébastien progrès et tout en étant
très très sérieux et respectueux il
reste quand même y avait une remise en
cause je suis un certain poids de la
stratégie gouvernementale
donc pour le gouvernement ça va être dur
ce parce que ces nouveaux d'accepter que
des gens qui posent des questions qui
critiquent et j'ai de la sympathie pour
eux et j'espère qu'ils vont bien le
prendre
qui réagiront pas trop être positivement
aux critiques ce que je crois que je
pense que le gouvernement s'attend
à ces critiques là parce que quand on
invoque une mesure comme le couvre-feu
qui à peu près jamais été utilisée au
québec et pas du tout dans l'air la
culture même canadienne pas juste
québécoise c'est plus fréquent en europe
on le voit depuis le début de la
première vague au québec c'est
extrêmement rare inévitablement ça vient
avec des crises des critiques des
questions est ce que le prix politique
va être particulièrement virulent j'en
suis pas certain déjà cet automne
sondage léger qui avait demandé ce que
les québécois seraient favorables à un
couvre-feu ce les mesures et les mesures
sanitaires s'avérer inefficaces ou pas
suffisant et 20 63 % des québécois qui
disaient oui enfin on en fin de semaine
y avait un sondage crop dans la presse
qui disait que 70 % des québécois était
d'accord avec les mesures il reste un
tiers des gens qui ne sont pas d'accord
sarkozy qui vont pas se conformer mais
qui trouve que ça vaut peut-être loin un
peu mais d'un point de vue politique
lorsqu'une décision est relativement
appuyées par 65 à 70% de la population
généralement on passe au travers on
n'est pas dans des situations à 95 %
comme le prétendent mais à 70% je pense
le gouvernement peut dire normalement
les gens me suis il faudrait pas que ça
se prolonge trop longtemps faudra t il
ya une certaine efficacité autour de la
mesure
mais pour l'instant je pense que le
gouvernement est relativement
confortable avec ça c'est ce que
j'allais dire il va falloir quand même
relativement vite
hélène que l'on voit décliné entre le
taux de positivité à tout le moins elle
est forte on voit qu'ils à cannes qu'un
fruit à tout ça oui absolument il y
avait une citation d'un ministre
guilbaud le qui disait c'est un succès
les deux premiers jours attention on ne
mesure pas le succès du couvre-feu par
son respect on le mesure par son effet
on fait pas un couvre feu juste pour
faire un couvre-feu
on le fait pour faire diminuer le nombre
de cas et ça évidemment ça va prendre
plusieurs jours voire jusqu'à deux
semaines avant qu'on envoie les faits et
moi je dois avouer je suis une de celles
qui est un peu critique puisqu'on ne
nous ont pas démontré l'impact que cela
pourrait avoir
je me croise les doigts que doivent
faire de même à demain lorsqu'il nous
annoncera de nouvelles mesures ne
n'annoncera pas de couvre feu simplement
parce que les deux provinces par
ailleurs ou de mesures assez similaire
bon l'école est peut-être un peu plus
retardé en ontario mais globalement on a
à peu près les mêmes approches si
l'ontario n'avait pas le couvre-feu
on pourra comme sa mesure et les faits
réels de du couvre-feu québécois moi je
soupçonne que la grosse aux cons adecco
auquel ont accès à laquelle on assiste
s'explique par les rassemblements
illégaux qu'on a eu pendant noël et que
par la force des choses le retour au
travail le retour à l'école de tout le
monde fera 10 mai l'école et son on sera
en mesure de le comparer si l'ontario et
sa petite affaire et que ça ne recule
pas de coureurs alors n'accroît pas lire
là on ne croit pas qu'il est en ce
moment
non parce que c'est pas vraiment dans la
culture conservatrice la de
libertarienne peu de liberté pour tous
tôt le devrais je dire
alors ça nous surprendrait beaucoup mais
monsieur x nous a surpris avant alors
que je ne prendrai pas de paris là
dessus pour l'instant
bon très bien alors à suivre pire il
faut quand même rappeler que deux nuits
alors il faut être patient peut avoir
des résultats mais quand même il faudra
qu'il y en ait parce que sinon c'est
quand même un effort n'est pas auprès
d'un si grand nombre de personnes
mais à des gens pour toutes sortes de
raisons qui à 9 heures le soir aurait eu
besoin d'aller mais même si on sortait
pas en pratique c'est un symbole
puissant ouais quand même un couvre-feu
est juste rapidement moi c'est un peu
spécifique et b quoi cette espèce de
solidarité très forte autour du
gouvernement et ça pendant des effets
pervers je trouve ça important qu'on
accepte la critique parce que
l'agressivité la frustration risque de
se reporter sur des boucs émissaires
je prends le bus un peu au québec une
très grande solidarité si on compare
avec la france des français vous les
connaissez ils ont critiqué depuis le
début de la crise le gouvernement et je
parlais hier à une québécoise qui est en
france depuis 30 ans et elle me dit ici
a pas beaucoup d'agressivité à l'égard
de ceux qui respectent pas les conseils
on n'est pas d'accord mais vous
connaissez je veux dire c'est trop du
d'orienter non plus c'est pas bon en
fait j'aurais très bien et puis un mot
sur les vaccins quand même avant de se
laisser parce que là il ya la semaine
dernière on s'envoyait
motif le québec monsieur legault qui
râlaient qui a twitté en fin de semaine
en disant on est à 60 18 % des doses
reçues s'est rendu à 80 donc oui très
bien mais encore on veut que ça on veut
que ça s'améliore pour tout le monde
partout là ouais on en avait parlé au
panel je pense que c'était judy pas très
sûr on dit que ça avait été assez
inélégant de part et d'autre autant de
talent du côté des provinces la semaine
dernière en se lacérant de se trouver un
bouc-émissaire marquer des points
politiques si on n'a pas assez de doses
dont ceux des provinces qu'ils avaient
mais n'est-ce pas assez rapidement alors
que dans le fond la population pour un
ange est aussi crucial veuve-clicquot
gouvernements collaborent et on veut que
ça fonctionne on peut pas savoir c'est
la faute à qui on veut qu'on règle le
problème et on ne s'est entendu d'après
ce que je comprends jeudi soir la
réunion entre justin trudeau et les
premiers ministres des provinces pour
baisser le ton un peu de part et d'autre
essayer de collaborer davantage m -
couteaux tirés publiquement parce
qu'effectivement ce genre de chose qui
peut agacer les gens puissent est je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui françois legault
son ton était plus calme
oui on a rappelé que le fédéral a la
responsabilité de trouver les deux mois
on n'a pas décroché de flèches
on n'a pas attaqué trudeau de manière
frontale lors du point de presse
peut-être qu'effectivement le tout le
monde essaie de faire de son mieux alors
moment donné il faut aussi capable de
d'en prendre puis d'admettre l'état de
chacun sans ce qu'on est et du doigt l
île et notre mosquée autour de trucs
dont on lui a dit peut-être bronches en
changeant de stratégie ce n'est pas en
attaquant les provinces qu'on va marquer
des points mais on a senti que ça a été
mal reçus puis ça je trouve que ça a mis
en lumière le fait que le gouvernement
fédéral manque de connaissance du
terrain il regarder ça de très haut de
très loin beaucoup manquent
d'administration doses alors qu' il y
avait des des réalités logistique qui
expliquait la situation et qu'il aura
échappé et ça ça pourrait leur nuire par
la suite s'il décède sans traiter dans
cette idée le d'imposer des normes
nationales dans les centres de personnes
200 de soins pour personnes âgées là
mais je trouve aussi que tout ce que ça
nous monde sait qu'il faut faire
attention le nombre de doses est
tellement petit par rapport à l'ensemble
la population que chaque fois qu'on
regarde les chiffres on demande aux
administrés versus temps de vaccins
disponibles
c'est vraiment juste un instantané dans
le temps ça dépend
du jour où vous l'avez pris et en bout
de piste note clairement les promesses
les provinces font à peu près toutes au
même rythme c'est à dire à peu près le
plus vite possible qu'elles qu'elles
peuvent le voir que ça cloche à quelque
part avant de cesser avant de conclure
là que tout est croche faut peut-être se
donnait une semaine ou deux encore
qu'ici en conclusion l'étude
je trouve que au niveau québécois puis
au niveau des autres provinces comme les
hellènes tout semble bien se passer pour
le bien expliqué après midi puis on sait
contrôler à l'égard d'une certaine
agressivité d'ottawa mais reste quand
même qu'il faut le noter il ya juste
cinq cent mille vaccins au canada je
trouve que le gendre m dos a réussi de
façon exceptionnelle son opération de
relations publiques quand les premiers
vaccins sont arrivés souvenez vous
reparler de l'espoir tout le monde était
ému c'est vrai mais g une réalité qui
est quand même froide de 500000 29
millions voilà messieurs dames
merci beaucoup bon bonne semaine à vous
on va continuer à très bientôt
au revoir le roi avant